et 25,8 pour 180 au premier tour chirac
c'était 20 895 19,9 en 2002 donc il faut
arrêter de nous marteler sur 24 pour
seront à la hauteur de ce qui s'est
passé pour vous ma finesse et très bon
moment écoutez il a été première
objection
on ne peut pas prendre ce score de
premier tour sans la voir prendre
également pour les prédécesseurs ce
qu'on ne faisait pas à l'époque
deuxièmement deuxièmement je ne pense
pas que le autant je pense que le vote
entre guillemets anti fasciste est
quelque chose qui était prédominant demi
le haut je pense que c'est sale et
beaucoup beaucoup moins il y a dix mille
manières de le démontrer en 2017 et je
vous préviens tout de suite ça
n'existera plus en 2022 se passe kerry
troisième et dernier point on ne peut
pas passer par pertes et fracas pertes
et profits confie avec les élections
législatives sous prétexte que la
participation et étaient plusieurs
points en dessous non c'est pas une
raison non plus je dire personne ne
pensait avant l'élection présidentielle
qui l'aurait majorité absolue sans cesse
de tri il ya un sujet de la légitimité
et le jet du socle électoral politique
la légimité elle est évidemment pas en
cause
évidemment il essayait l'huile à gagner
d'un projet le problème c'est la
fragilité du sexe est celle là les réels
aussi et là je viserai depuis 1974
merkel maintenant au delà il est
particulièrement pour deux raisons y'a
que les opus mais ce que je veux faire
maintenant l'idée là il ya quelque chose
je crois vraiment que ce qui les
conditions d'élection sont très
particulières je ferai un camp équipe
rapport ce que dit jérôme je crois pas à
la sphère anti-fasciste oui en 2002
celle anti fascistes de pacotille là
c'est pas ça c'est le rejet des deux
autres il est il est vrai les gens ne
veulent pas de fillon parce que fillon
est pris la main dans le pot de
confiture et alors qu'il était parti
pour la gloire gens disent on ne veut
plus de ce gala et ils ne veulent pas de
marine le pen et non pas tant à cause de
la sphère fasciste parce qu'il n'ya plus
du sort tellement de faillite simplement
il ya la peur de l'euro il ya maintenant
il ya comme la peur de rouhia sa nullité
au débat donc elle
les deux votes rejetés les deux votes
rejetés et donc macro le produit de ce
rejet ça change rien à sa légitimité
c'est simplement que quand on est élu
par 24 % de 80% on avait pourtant de
partisans ben en vérité il à 20% de
partisans ça pourrait enfin le socle
électoral c'est ça qui compte
bien sûr qu'elle est démocratiquement
indiscutable et indiscuté d'ailleurs
enfin tout de même à partir de
mitterrand giscard d'estaing 74,4 on a
eu une opposition entre la droite gauche
à des élections
j'allais dire aux présidentielles normal
prévisible avec des blogs qui incarnait
quelque chose de profondes dans les
familles politiques françaises là on
sait bien que une affaire politico
médiatico judiciaire a faussé
complètement écartée a donné à des
électeurs par exemple de fillon au
premier tour un sentiment de rancoeur
même si au deuxième tour ils ont voté
pour
pour macron pour faire barrage à madame
le pen bon c'était la légitimité
indiscutable en même temps elle est un
peu rongé a priori peuvent pas en faire
fi il est sûre il ailleurs il le dit lui
même je vais arriver le mais j'ai su
après que la colère un coupon courbon
très bien c'est la loi mais qui n'oublie
pas quoi olivier duhamel et puis la
parole est aux interventions peuvent
tout petit peu dépassé notre controverse
on peut convenir entre nous que les
votes de sont de plus en plus des vote
de rejet et pas des votes d'adhésion et
signale je signale contre toute la
vision française des choses que y'a plus
d'électeurs de jam qui ont voté dom par
rejet de clinton que des lecteurs de
clinton qui voter clinton parlait de
tschopp il faut ajouter que la
participation étant de plus en plus
faibles les socles mécaniquement se
fragilise son jugement dernier
alors on les attend les internautes
jérôme à ccc la braunhie tôt d'autres je
ne crois pas que bonito nous dit je ne
crois pas qu'un débat de qualité puisse
se faire à plusieurs millions de
personnes d'où les démocraties
représentatives
monsieur babineau comment faire le tri
dans les milliers de doléances et des
ch'ti qui nous dit le débat impose une
lenteur d'action et un immobilisme
nuisibles cela ne devrait être réservée
qu'aux questions de fond comme les
réformes constitutionnelles un
gouvernement est élu pour mettre en
place le programme prévu lors des
élections pas pour en débattre pendant
cinq ans et ben justement ça nous ramène
quand même au coeur de notre sujet parce
que c'était ça un peu la question
on dit toujours finalement cinq ans est
déjà très court pour appliquer un
programme alors pourquoi remettre les
choses en cause au milieu oui je sais
pas enfin j'ai pas de jeu c'est ça il
n'a pas le choix écoutez je sais
pourquoi il voulait par ailleurs 8% soit
posé une question sur le quinquennat bon
j'ai pas donner voilà rien à dire de
particulier mais soit effectivement
pourquoi est ce qu'il fait cela
faut voir aussi qu'un tiens en jeu à
court terme dans cette consultation
premier choix très rapidement des 30%
d'après le dernier sondage je croyais
lab ou 30 % des gens qui sont nettement
opposée au mouvement ni gilet jaune
vous avez 30 % des gens qui sont
nettement en soutien et vous avez 30 %
des gens qui sont sympathisants
alors on peut dire c'est 60 contre 30
pas exactement là il ya un vrai enjeu
parmi les 30 % de ceux qui ont la
sympathie pour le mouvement sans
réellement soutenir pour dire bon pour
décrocher pour dire là le président de
la république fait le maximum
on donne la parole au peuple il a
réclame on la leur donne s'ils
continuent à tout bloquer c'est plus
possible et donc là il ya un enjeu ce
qu'on dit qu'est ce que ça va donner en
trois mois ou bien dans trois mois c'est
l'important c'est de savoir dans les
airs dix semaines qu'il ya la crise et
la crise continue ses moyens de gagner
du temps ces vols dans les entreprises
c'est la même chose on l'avait vu avec
le cip et quand il quand il ya le feu
qui prend on se donne du temps et donc
en autre internaute dit on perd du temps
pour les réformer oui mais ça sert à ça
précisément c'est fait pour gagner du
temps en l'air et essayer de faire que
les choses s'apaisent en essayant en
espérant tenir jusqu'aux européennes la
vraie question est là est-ce que ça
permettra de calmer les choses
jusque pour tenir jusqu'aux européennes
sans changement majeur qui de toute
façon on devra bien intervenir à un
moment ou un autre
crise de la démocratie représentative
une crise politique en crise morale sur
fond d'économie parole luisantes ça fait
beaucoup à la fois c'est il n'est pas
responsable de tout mais il essaie son
destin d'un peu bouc émissaire de tous
faux gras dans un moment qui sommes à
commande dans un moment de long et à
deux longueurs de défiance
la déception à l'égard du terroir est
devenu l'inéluctable règles et si la
nappe à son programme
on le lui reproche de ne pas respecter
la souveraineté du peuple qui l'a élu
et s'il applique son programme on lui
reproche de ne pas écouter le peuple qui
matent on veut un autre déception est
inéluctable les équipes
les uns ne se transforme pas en crédits
au profit des autres c'est à dire que
c'est comme si ces couches de discrédit
qui se superposent la gauche a raté la
droite a raté sarkozy finalement on a
rejeté la droite et puis la gauche rate
on rejette la gauche mc on rate on
rejette macro mais ça revient pas c'est
ça qui est très très nouveau
quelques réactions korb ronito les
débats doivent être ponctuel gouverner
c'est suivre une ligne directrice et
monsieur babineau les français ne
souhaite pas débattre mais plutôt
disposer d'une capacité de décision au
travers de référendum
alors la question que vous posez sur
twitter peut-on gouverné par le débat
permanent
vous êtes une large majorité a estimé
que non 73%
olivier duhamel dans votre petit livre
les mots de macron qui est paru l'an
dernier chez dalloz vous fait un
abécédaire des citations du président
avant même qu'il soit président j'ai
retrouvé
j'ai été chercher le mot débat et voilà
ce qu il alors c'était une
un entretien je pense une contribution
qui l'avait donné à la revue esprit ça
date de 2011 et voilà ce qu'il disait
emmanuel macron à l'époque rien n'est
fait on peut lire à l'écran rien n'est
fait pour que dans une démocratie
je raccourcis les débats puissent
prendre place et se décliner selon une
temporalité des modalités adaptées le
temps politique vit dans la préparation
du spasme présidentielle autour duquel
tout se contracte et lors duquel tous
ces problèmes doivent trouver une
réponse il avait bien identifié les
données du problème
oui tu as peut-être un petit peu oublié
après cette contribution après les
années passant il rappelé
et donc c'est très bien du rap et
d'ailleurs vous êtes gentils citer cet
ouvrage social que je prépare une
nouvelle édition déjà et je renforcent
très fortement la partie qu'ils
appellent les mots qui dut là mais non
c'est une vraie c'est pour ça que jérôme
sainte-marie à raison qu'il ya la
première il ya la fonction de régler un
problème à court terme qui est celui de
la persistance du mouvement des gilet
jaune bien sûr c'est même le principal
j'en conviens mais il ya aussi l'idée de
tenter de reprendre sa formule à lui de
le réconcilier avec le peuple de dire
que lui ôteront dont on l'accuse de ne
jamais écouter de décider tout parent au
d'être si loin du peuple aussi l'idée
maintenant c'est pour ça qu'il ya
rebattre toutes les questions sont
permis quelques quoi qu'il arrive je
répondrais et settat de route de re qui
sut le fils quand même
alexis vous disiez tout à l'heure où le
débat ça avant surtout l'objectif de
gagner du temps emmanuel macron il
emploie maintenant souvent ce mot de
nouveau contrat social alors ça c'est du
pipeau comme vous aviez l'air de ça
quand c'est vrai nom s'il est fait non
mais
c'est parti il va par bâtir quelque
chose d'entièrement neuf là pendant
trois mois ou tous alors que tout va mal
que tout le monde le déteste qui a les
héros plein au bout non il peut essayer
de calmer le jeu de effectivement
renouer en tout cas de faire baisser
l'hostilité qui aujourd'hui le frappe
dans tous les domaines quoi qu'il fasse
quoi qu'ils disent est toujours mal donc
il peut essayer de faire baisser
l'intensité de ce rejet est espérée
après quelque chose qui est anticipé
l'intensité salé est espéré à l'occasion
après les européennes qui s'annonce
quand même qu'une défaite à ce moment-là
ayant fait baisser l'intensité dur j'ai
essayé de repartir
voilà c'est une phase ii où on se
rassemble c'est pas du tout sûr que ça
marche mais c'est pas ne sais pas le
nouveau contrat social non ça n'existe
pas denis tillinac à un mot là-dessus
mais non je ne crois que ce que disaient
d'accord sauf que après les en fait le
moment crucial c'est les élections
européennes
elles seront pas bonnes pour les amis de
maquereaux même avec le le le
un juppé qui lui donnera un coup de main
donc à partir de soi mal c'est de là
qu'il faudra celle là il faudra car non
pas nouveau contrat social mais pour le
moins une nouvelle façon de gouverner
avec un nouveau dégagisme il a été
victime d'un dégagé il faut qu'il le
fasse autour de lui et ça me paraît le
plus urgent il ya d'autres éléments
possibles mais encore une fois encore
une fois faire l'apologie des manuels
macron il n'est pas exclu que sa
politique fonctionne il n'est pas ou si
peu exclu que finalement elles
produisent des résultats pour la france
est pour l'instant les français les
brevets ce mari l'a fait pas 60% des
français considèrent que les réformes se
fait se font contre leur intérieur
présente pour cent c'était pas le cas
avant l'été et donc hélas elle se
voulait une voix pas de résultats
tangibles
on peut penser que si effectivement le
fouloir gagne du temps et bien ces
résultats annoncés finiront pas
reproduire ce n'est pas une réforme du
droit du travail aussi nécessaire soit
elle est un enfant de la sncf mais aussi
des zergs dames qui vont changer sa
politique il vient d'annoncer qu'il
arrêtait et c'est pendant ces trois ou
quatre mois à nom de famille quand on
distribue 12 milliards et qu'on lance un
grand débat ça veut dépendre ni la
réforme des retraites ni la réforme de
l'accueil sur ce match ni la réforme de
la fonction publique accusations vont
continuer de toute c par exemple souvent
dans des trucs mais ce n'est pas sa
retraite il va qui va se refaire la
cerise
vous le savez rien au fait ce genre de
chose il va faire du sociétal pour
récupérer un peu à gauche qu'il est en
train de perdre à droite et il n'y aura
pas de nouveau contrat social
alors il y en a d'autres qui sont
empêtrés dans un débat qui compliquait
c'est celui du break site sauf énième
renonce le rebond 10